pursuant to executive order 20204
this public body is authorized to meet
electronically
this is a public hearing on bills okay
let's see please note that there is no
physical location for members of the
public to observe and to listen
contemporaneously to this meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order i am confirming that all members
of the committee and select legislative
staff
have the ability to communicate
contemporaneously during this meeting
through the zoom electronic meeting
platform and the public has access to
content to contemporaneously listen and
if necessary participate in this meeting
by the zoom platform or by telephone
all necessary access information has
been made available in the house
calendar
and through the electronic calendar on
the general court website
the notice for this meeting complies
with house rules in rsa 91a
anyone who has a problem accessing this
meeting should call 271
3600 or email hcs
at ledge.state.nh.us
in the event the public is unable to
access this meeting the meeting will be
adjourned and rescheduled
please note that all votes that are
taken during this meeting shall be done
by roll call vote
and we will start the meeting today by
taking a roll call attendance
when each member states their presence
please also state whether there is
anyone in the room with you during this
meeting which is required under the
right to know law
um and to sort of double up our
attendance and our stating whether
anyone is in the room
with our introductions it would be great
if each of you could just state
your name where you're from um perhaps
what grade you are in
and as well as you know your presence
and whether there is anyone in the room
and if you could share just for our
guests the interest groups that you're
part of or perhaps an issue that you
care about
that would be great as well um
so i can begin and then i'll go down the
list of attendees
so my name is elena drondo and i am the
co-chair of the new hampshire
legislative youth advisory council
i live in bedford and i am a junior in
high school and
some of the interest groups that i'm a
part of are voting rights and climate
action
and with that we'll pass it on to
well rep alexander would you like to
thank yourself yeah i just want to
welcome representative
thank you for coming um i sent you the
agenda so right now we're just doing
introductions
um and then we'll we'll pass it off to
you if that works
perfect thank you so much for coming um
yeah joe alexander live in goffstown
happy to be here
i'm 26 years old i don't go to school
anymore but it was fun
well it lasted
awesome all right um let's go
there is a she her from manchester new
hampshire i'm not sure
the name isn't there but if you'd like
to introduce yourself
see i'm not sure what that might be um
but i'll pass it to carson in that case
okay
uh so my name is carson go um i live in
nashville new hampshire
i'm currently a senior and i go to
nashville north
and the interest groups i'm a part of is
the education and voting rights
awesome harrison would you like to go
next
hi my name is harrison smaltoff i am a
junior at goffstown high school and i'm
a part of the education
and gun control interest groups
great isabel my name is isabel povey i
am a junior at pinkerton academy and i
am
a member of climate action and
healthcare interest groups
thanks so much jude
my name's jude farley um i'm also a
junior at pinkerton
um and i'm currently an alternate so i'm
not on any interest groups
casey uh
my name is casey reagan i'm a senior at
woodrow high school
and i'm in the social justice and
several diseases
we're having a bit of trouble hearing
you but i think it sort of went through
um well thank you so much for coming i'm
so sorry
yeah no worries that happens all the
time it wouldn't be a zoom meeting
without
one technical difficulty or another um
let's see
lily would you like to go sure my name
is lovely tag blow i am a junior at
manchester central
and my interest groups are climate and
healthcare
awesome maddie
hi my name is maddie i'm a senior from
pinkerton
and i'm a part of the climate and
healthcare interest groups and i don't
know if you still want this to say this
in this
um little like uh list going down but
no one else is in the room would be
great thank you
and thanks so much for joining us kevin
all right meg
hi i'm meg sawyer i'm a sophomore at
the university of new hampshire and
there's no one in the room
and i'm on voting reform and gun control
molly
hi i'm molly ewing i'm from nottingham
i'm a senior at ko brown
and i'm on the gun control and um
substance abuse um committees
awesome reed hello
i'm reid i'm from francestown new
hampshire i'm a senior at conval high
school
and i am on the substance abuse and
social equity committees and no one is
in the room
ryan hi i'm ryan mcmahon i'm a junior at
pinkerton
and i'm on the healthcare education and
voting reform committees
and no one's in the room with me great
and last but not least sam
hi i am sam quinn i am from concord
and i am on the education and voting
reform
interest groups awesome thank you all so
much for coming and i'll quickly pass it
over to introductions from both of our
guests but we'll
we'll go back to you soon with um the
next part of our meeting which is just
hearing from you about hb544
um but usma would you like to introduce
yourself
absolutely thank you so much for
inviting me my name is ismael huni and
i'm the movement politics director with
rights and democracy in new hampshire
we are an organization that promotes
human rights we have chapters in both
new hampshire and vermont
thanks for inviting me thank you so much
for coming and
representative ammon
yeah my name is representative keith
ammon and
this is my third term in the house and
i'm the prime prime sponsor of the bill
we'll be discussing hospital 544.
thank you all it's really a pleasure to
get to hear from you and um
we're really looking forward to
discussing this bill and to all of our
members
we've sent out the link to this
legislation and we hope that you had the
chance to review it and i can also drop
it um
in the chat once again in case you would
like to take a look
and this meeting will be um
a chance for us to learn more about it
as a council with a goal of us
voting on it to determine a stance at
the end of our meeting
um so without further ado um we will be
passing it on to each of our guest
speakers to hear the perspectives for
and against this bill
and have the opportunity to understand
you know their rationale and also ask
any questions that we might have
so um as you may all see in our agenda
we have
about 20 minutes for each of our guest
speakers and
after that we will deliberate and vote
so
are there any questions about how this
meeting will run just to make sure we
address this before we dive in
all right um with that said thank you
all so much for coming and i will pass
it to representative ammon
um to hear as a sponsor of hp 544
um just from you as as a sponsor how you
uh your thoughts on the bill and then we
will open it up to any questions that
you all might have for him
great thank you for having me and uh
thank you to representative alexander
for the invite
and uh i appreciate you guys
doing your civic duty by being part of
the state legislature's
you know council this is really exciting
it gives you guys a good
lesson into how to get involved
civically so that's pretty cool
i don't know if you remember carlin
gargasse but she was a former
member of this committee and uh i heard
a lot about
what went on here from her so i live in
new boston uh
and i represent a super district it's
called a floaterial district
it goes down to milford and hollis down
to the massachusetts border
this is my third term i'm on the
commerce and consumer affairs committee
and i'm also an assistant whip for the
majority
so um you know i help to get vote counts
on different bills
house bill 544 as you know is a very
contentious bill it's caused a lot of
conversation
about the subject matter and
to me that's a good thing because it
gets us talking
about controversial issues and not being
afraid
to share our views and get a better
understanding
of issues and you know this one deals
with
the issues of racism and sexism
and you know we know that those are
morally reprehensible things we want to
get rid of those from our society as
much as possible and that's the
trajectory
that we've been on our as our state and
uh country are making progress on these
things
um there's a a movement
it's called critical race theory i saw
in the agenda
my my section was uh critical race
theory ban so i just want to set the
record straight
this bill doesn't ban critical race
theory
uh it doesn't even bend talking about
some of the subject matters of critical
race theory
what it does is it prevents taxpayer
money
from advocating towards a certain view
so for instance if you're in a class
and they discuss some of the tenets of
critical race theory we get into that a
little bit
um that you wouldn't be you wouldn't
have to
fail or pass based on your
uh stating your belief in that theory
so think about it this way if
creationism was taught about in school
you could discuss it as some people
think
that this is the way the world works the
earth was created
seven days animals were created in this
order but you couldn't
the teacher couldn't pass or fail you
based on your stating that you believe
in creationism right we know that would
be wrong
um and so that's that's what house bill
does it takes some of the tenets of
critical race theory
it kind of just like brushes against the
edge of it
and some of the more controversial
positions that sometimes are used
to promote critical race theory and it
says we don't want to fund these with
taxpayer money
um so i'll here's what i don't want to
do i don't want to box against
shadows of what people say the bill says
i want to
i want to talk about what the bill
actually says so
um have have most of you read it who has
read it and who hasn't read it
so who has read it okay everybody's read
it okay
so it's it can be a little confusing the
way that it's set up but
if you've read it you went over the the
definitions of divisive concepts
and um you know i guess i don't have to
read all those for you because you've
all you've all read those but
two of them that really stand out is and
imagine
uh using taxpayer money to promote this
idea
that one race or sex is inherently
superior to another race or sex
we wouldn't want to use taxpayer money
to promote that idea
and another one that stands out an
individual should be discriminated
against
or receive adverse treatment solely or
partly because of his or her race or sex
so we wouldn't want to discriminate
against people or teach people to
discriminate against other people
based on their race or sex solely or
partly
um and then there's some other issues
here um
an individual's moral character we
wouldn't want to teach using taxpayer
money
that an individual's moral character is
necessarily
determined by his or her race or sex and
so that
this gets into the fundamental idea of
individual
uh rights so do you guys know the
difference between individualism
and collectivism that's kind of the
spectrum so like america
and uh maybe even eastern european
european traditions
well let's say let's just stick with
america because we kind of had to have a
revolution about this issue but
um we're focused on individual liberty
and that doesn't mean you're selfish it
doesn't mean that all you care about is
yourself
what it means is that the individual is
supreme that
our beliefs our our thoughts our uh
conscience only emanates from within
each of us
as individuals um that the group is
secondary to the
individual and if you look at maybe like
communist china they kind of reverse
that
that the group that the individual has
to subordinate themselves to the group
and so um that's why we don't want to
judge people
based on attributes that they were born
with whether
they're born a certain sex or a certain
race we don't want to say
because you're part of this group
therefore we're going to ascribe
these negative character traits to you
that it's the individual's actions it's
our
our deeds as an individual that we
should be judged
on and um you know you've heard the
quote people say it a million times
it's uh martin luther king that we would
want a society that where we're judged
based on the content
of our character not the color of our
skin and so
um that's just kind of like a prelude
to what the bill is trying to address is
that we're
we're not going to use taxpayer money
and that's what the bill addresses it's
about spending
uh taxpayer funds uh to promote these
ideas
even if it's called diversity training
so you can call something diversity
training
and then you can kind of um you know
diversity training would be
uh diversity is something we strive for
inclusion is something we strive for
um but if if you
try to promote that one race or sex is
inherently good or bad based on
how someone was born then that would be
kind of a violation
of you know what america is about
so i'll just i'll just mention two
things so if you've read the bill
on page two
the requirements for the state i don't
know if you guys have this in front of
you
so the the main things are um one and
two there so i'm looking at page two
it's line
one if you have the pdf sorry line 11 if
you have the pdf version
and uh it says the state of new
hampshire shall not teach instruct or
train any employee contractor staff
member student
or any other individual group and here's
the key words to adopt or believe
so to adopt or believe is that's the key
word
and sometimes opponents to the bill kind
of leave that they push that aside
they simply they overly simplify it uh
to say that you can't talk about
these things and that's not true you can
talk about them
as long as you're not passing or failing
someone for adopting or believing
in those things you see that difference
and then the second section there i'm
looking at line 14 on the pdf version
no employee contractor staff member
student of the state of new hampshire
shall face any penalty
or discrimination on account of his or
her refusal to support believe endorse
embrace confess
act upon or otherwise it's sent to the
divisive concept so
you can learn about the divisive
concepts but if someone says
you will fail this class if you don't
say you believe in them
or in one of them or you know then that
would be against this bill that would be
discrimination against
your right to conscience so your your
right to believe what you want to
and then just a couple of things that
i'll point out um
sometimes people say oh this spans
diversity inclusion training
or even that abandons talking about the
holocaust or talking about women's
suffrage
so there's a tactic in politics where
you create a strong man argument against
your opponent so instead of talking
about what the bill really says
you make this imaginary version of
whatever you're fighting against
and then you project that out into the
public discourse and then
the people trying to support the other
side have
have trouble trying to say no that's not
what it says that's not what it says
um because it's you know it's out there
that's what the public uh
has been told to believe right and
that's why i want to stress
actually reading the language of the
bill because
um it's not what someone's imagination
of what the bill says that counts it's
what it actually says that's what
becomes law
so um page three
it's line 32 so people say this bans
diversity and inclusion trainings well
it says agency diversity and inclusion
efforts shall first and foremost
encourage agency employees not to judge
each other by their
color race ethnicity sex or any other
characteristic
protected by federal or state law
so i think you know most people would
agree that that's what
diversity inclusion training should do
it should encourage agency employees not
to judge each other by those traits
and then finally it says you know the
opponents will say this will
prohibit talking about this in the
classroom well
my rebuttal to that would be again
language from the bill page 4
line 21 it says nothing in this chapter
shall be construed
to prohibit discussing as part of a
larger course of
academic descrip instruction the
divisive concepts listed
in an objective manner and without
endorsement
so i use that example with creationism
you know some people sincerely believe
that creationism
is how the world was made but we don't
use taxpayer money to
promote um that people need to
adopt and believe something that should
be left
to the you know our private thoughts and
so
you know that's really the focus of the
bill now how much time do i have left
you haven't got i want to leave time for
questions
that would be great thank you but i
wanna i wanna just say one thing to you
guys
um so this is part of a larger
discussion that's happening nationally
about um it's mainly about race but it's
about sexism too um
and you hear the term critical race
theory you put it in the agenda
and what what proponents of critical
race theory don't tell you
and i i want you to research this on
your own
is that critical race theory is part of
a set of theories
called critical theories so there's
critical
you know legal theory there's different
critical theories
but it traces its roots back to uh
marxism
traces its roots back to the frankfurt
school
uh which was in germany in the 1930s
that it's it's part of that lineage of
thought
and it's really to divide people
into do two different groups so like
classical marxism divided people into
the
capital you know the the bourgeoisie and
the proletariat right the labor class
working class and the capital class
but this is using race to divide people
and there's a there's an underlying
agenda behind it is to gain political
power that's what
pretty much every um every advocacy
is about usually about gaining political
power
so if you if you dig into critical race
theory and again 544 doesn't bend
talking about it
and all it does is say um these really
really divisive uh fringe
ideas that some people who support
critical race their use
we wouldn't want to use taxpayer money
and
train people or teach people that this
is the only way this is the only way to
think
so you know it's part of the larger
discussion that's okay but asking you're
failing somebody on it
would be wrong this this has been really
helpful and it's been great to hear your
opinion
and um rationale for introducing this um
and if if possible it would be great to
open it up to some questions since our
time is a bit limited today
um but before that i did have a quick
question for you about
um this idea of using taxpayer money um
and you know the
the reasons behind this bill would it be
possible to have a couple of
examples and scenarios in which you know
without this bill taxpayer money
would be or currently is being used in
order to propagate these concepts um and
how does that kind of
show up in our society as it is now yeah
that's a great question
um so
uh in the manchester school district
it showed up as part of a teacher
training uh
where uh there's a concept and i'm gonna
say it and it's gonna sound like i'm
supporting something that's bad and i
want you to kind of think about
what the word means but an
anti-whiteness
training so that was part of the the
manchester school district and it's not
about whether it's white or black or
brown or whatever color it's about
dividing people based on skin color and
saying that
certain people are deficient because
they were born a certain way and others
you know maybe they're deficient in a
different way or but that
we're not all part of the same society
in the same group
and so it actually causes the vision um
you know in my view that's what it does
is it causes the vision because we're
all individuals we're all
citizens in the same country and
you know you've heard the term systemic
racism
and there is racism there's a history of
racism in our country
but when if you this is another thing
i'd like you to research if you could
systemic
racism what what they're saying is that
the system
our the system of our country was
designed from the beginning in all its
institutions and all the rules and all
the laws
were designed to perpetuate racism
and that's a really big statement i mean
that's sort of like calling america nazi
germany
right so we know you know the
concentration camps
uh with the jews were bad and america's
done some bad things don't get me wrong
but we're our society is designed to be
self-correcting
and self-healing so uh to say that we
need to throw the whole thing out
and have a revolution and you know
turn every turn turn over every system
and create something new
i disagree with that point of view i
think the way that our country
was set up from the founding allows it
to heal itself to self-correct
because you know for one thing we have
conversations like this or we can
disagree
and make up our own minds and that gets
us further
uh towards you know what they say a more
perfect union
thank you so much um does anyone else
have any questions
lily about you hi um
so i appreciate you telling us all about
the bill you know i read the build text
and the one thing that i didn't
understand is
this build wouldn't this bill only make
sense if we assume that
nobody is given any privilege based on
race or gender or sex
do you think that is true or do you
think that is not true
so you're talking about privilege okay
yes
so uh privilege that term is kind of
like
a and this is my opinion you can take it
for what it's worth
it's kind of like a political talking
point
um there are there are lots of types of
privilege in the world
right if you're if you're attractive to
look at or you're not attractive to look
at if you're left-handed or right-handed
right if you're tall or short if you're
the inner fat uh
if you're born to wealthy parents or not
right
there's lots of types of privilege uh in
the world
and by focus by trying to make people
feel
guilty for how they were born uh you
know collective guilt
goes against that idea of individualism
that i was telling you about earlier
that
uh to try to tell someone that they
should feel guilty for being born a
certain way
even if they're born to rich parents
right like it could be like lebron
lebron james kids or you know just pick
an example where
it doesn't quite fit the paradigm that
we're talking about
um that's just the way the world is we
need to come together and uh
you know it's some of it's hard work on
our own part
to bridge those gaps and some of it is
you know
you sprinkle a little bit of luck on
getting ahead but there's lots of types
of privilege in the world
not just the color of your skin so
that's that would be my response to that
so that didn't answer my question it did
it said it said your question focuses on
a very narrow
uh aspect of what privilege is in
privilege that label has become
a uh it's a political talking point and
i just described to you that there's
lots of types of privilege
so okay really if you really if you
don't mind i'm going to give an
opportunity to other people for
follow-ups and
if we have time at the end you can do
that yeah that works really quick
so you're talking about certain groups
gaining political power
who do you who are those groups are they
groups based on like gender or sex or
who are you yeah no it's not based on
that it's like
it goes back to what i was saying
earlier that there's a there's an
underlying agenda behind
this stuff um and it traces its roots
back to marxism and
maybe some of you guys think marxism is
a great thing but there's been
you know hundreds of millions of people
have died because it doesn't actually
work
capitalism capitalism is not great
and uh you know we can do some we can
improve what we have currently but
um you know that that's what i think is
underlying this is um
trying to control people's actions and
uh
you know i should be free to trade with
you and you should be free to trade with
me
and we could pull our resources to trade
with other people
that's really you know the way i think
things should work um thank you so much
we are pressed for time so i wanna
get in a couple more questions does
anyone have any
i see uh sam's hands been up thank you
what
yeah hi so thank you representative for
coming in and talking to us
so my question is uh could a school
district
uh give a an implicit bias training
to their faculty uh
with this bill in effect with this
legislation
yeah but you what you couldn't do is say
um
you know you couldn't isolate people by
how they were born and say you people
over here have this kind of implicit
bias because you're born a certain way
and those people over there they have a
different implicit bias because they are
born as earthquake
as long as you're doing it uniformly
treating everybody equally as
individuals
then that there's nothing wrong with
that you see the difference there
yes thank you no any further questions
i see uh meg has a hand up too go ahead
yeah hi um thanks for taking the time to
talk with us today
um my question is when you um
talk about how schools much
they can teach about divisive concepts
as long as it's
in an objective manner
and without endorsement um how do you
see that
being different from the way it's
currently taught like do you see a lot
of examples where
students like you mentioned are being
failed because they
they won't um accept
certain theories
and also
uh we're not i missed the last part of
your question it was
breaking up meg if you tried to
turn off your video and try asking the
question again that'd be great
can you hear me now yeah
okay do you hear me now yep
okay so my the second part was who gets
to determine
like like how are you going to review
whether it was taught
in objective manner without endorsement
yeah that's a great question um in the
public school it would be up to
um the parents to you know the students
and the parents
to raise an objection and then it would
go to the school board
and they would review you know any
evidence uh for it and maybe that would
be
uh you know course curricula or what the
questions were on the test
here's an example in hanover the the
hanover school district
uh had a test and it said when
when did america become a racist country
and it had six multiple choice questions
on it
and the correct answer the one that you
would pass if you answered correctly
was when the declaration of independence
was signed that was the correct answer
on that test
that would be uh an example of
you know promoting something uh
not objectively and trying to endorse a
certain position that you know
that would be a pretty blatant example
so
all right i want to make sure that we
give both sides equal time so um
we'll uh have ryan would you like to ask
a question we can make that one the
final one i can give
um snug the uh the other time
uh that's okay i'll let her speak on
that
okay perfect if we have any further
questions would we be able to reach you
through email so that we can get them
answered
yeah so if you guys know how to look up
on the general court the gen court
website
my email is on there um and
stick to the language of the bill if you
could that would be uh you know
helpful for the discussion i think thank
you so much perfect
well thank you representative for
joining and um you're welcome to stick
around and
listen if you'd like okay i might i
might put it on uh
on speaker thank you perfect
all right asthma would you like to um
present sort of
your opinion on the bill and take some
questions yes absolutely
thank you so much first of all for
inviting me i am so impressed with
all of you your questions were brilliant
and spot-on
um so you heard a lot today uh including
capitalism marxism i'm like wow
so i'm just gonna stick to the bill
though so if you don't mind that's the
only thing i'd i'd like to address in
this
in this um meeting so this bill
uh hb 544 is a carbon copy of an
executive order that trump issued before
leaving presidency
um it's important to know that it's
important to know that because
we need to understand um what the
purpose of the bill
is and also how it was supposed to get
applied
so um we heard that it was an idea from
a university professor at least that's
what representative ammon has said
publicly
um a university professor from
new hampshire uh that and that's why he
sponsored the bill but that's
really not the case the bill even if it
was first introduced in new hampshire
as the first state to introduce it in
the legislature it literally took the
exact
language of trump's executive order so
it's really a part of a greater national
project
that intends to curb this movement to
try to address systemic racism
so we know that one of those people
being behind this
right-wing national project is a man by
the name of christopher
ruffo who's a former fellow at the
heritage foundation
so the heritage foundation is a
right-wing uh think tank and he actually
tweeted this quote
he says we have successfully frozen
their brand
and their brand they meaning those
people who are organizing
against addressing systemic racism so he
continues
we have successfully branded their uh
bram and then he says
critical race theory into the public
conversation
and are steadily driving up negative
perceptions
we will eventually turn it toxic as we
put all the various cultural insanities
under that brand
and he continues quote the goal is to
have the public read something crazy in
the newspaper
and immediately think critical race
theory we have decodified the term
and will recodify it to annex the entire
range of cultural
constructions that are unpopular with
americans
end quote that was tweeted on may 15
of this year unfortunately the person
who introduced this bill in new
hampshire representative
keith ammon has said publicly in the
legislature on video that anyone can
look at and see that systemic racism
does not exist
and claim that our country has rooted
out quote the last
vestiges already so that's important
context to give when talking about this
bill
um which is now in the budget which is
quite genius honestly because that means
you know like the state has to pass the
budget so it was kind of smart way to
make sure that
that it tries to get past so about the
bill
so the bill's language is quite
deceiving because on face value it looks
harmless
but the problem is the divisive concepts
which the bill is referring to
is literally flipping this idea of
racism on its
head and calling those who point out
systemic racism racists
against whites right and those pointing
out gender inequality
sexist against men so which is
absolutely ridiculous
so basically it's supposed to protect
people who are uncomfortable
when the topic of addressing systemic
racism comes
you know comes up because they feel
their identity somehow is being attacked
when people mention how brown and black
community
or how women are affected
institutionally by racism or sexism
right
so we believe that this is a fake
problem
and um that it's not really an issue
like they're making it out to be and the
majority of white people
and men as well have stated they
appreciate these conversations
about systemic racism and how
disproportionately it impacts people
differently
in our nations and these difficult
conversations have helped them
see the way basically that the the
system
has benefits them sometimes and and
others right
um and they say they've now become
better advocates because of those
conversations so the fact that people
are insinuating that when we say that
historically and currently women have
been discriminated against as a social
group
and it's benefiting men as a social
group and that society has discriminated
against people of color
and that somehow will make men or white
people feel like you know we're saying
women are superior to men or that people
of color are superior to white people is
is really
quite sad and something that really just
doesn't make sense
so um if the the the bill sponsor anyone
doesn't believe that systemic racism
truly exists anymore
he and those people that have this
belief are the reason why
we must have these honest conversations
that bills like this would prevent
because as long as we keep behaving like
everything is okay
we'll never address the racism and
sexism that plagues uh
and harms all of us quite frankly um
because you know if we continue to harm
women we're literally harming our
mothers and sisters when we continue to
harm
people of color we're also robbing
ourselves of the opportunity to live in
an amazing multicultural democracy
really fast i also want to address
critical race theory because this
keeps coming up so critical race theory
is this boogeyman
that quite interestingly like because
this bill doesn't address
critical race theory at all the notion
that one group or people
is inherently superior to another group
the language from the bill or that
like one group of people by virtue of
their race or sex ought to feel guilty
about the fact that they belong
to a race or section none of these
things have anything to do with critical
race theory
critical release theory is basically the
shedding light
of the fact that racism functions
differently today
and so this idea of color blindness
colorblindness is not allowing us to
notice the ways that racism does
function in our society today
it's saying that even when race is uh
it's saying basically that
uh you know racism doesn't have to be
mentioned for something to be racist
right racism still exists
and happy and happens even without
naming the word um
racism so it exists through racial
disparities inequality
racial discrimination and many like
disadvantages that research
has shown with data that impacts black
brown native americans that's critical
race theory
and the fact is um in america you know
america is racist that's just a fact
right and this bill would literally
punish me for saying so
but we have evidence right not just past
practices but today
and also america doesn't have to be
racist though
that's the key that's that's why these
conversations are necessary and
important right we do have a chance to
get better
to to truly live into that multi-racial
democracy
where all of us black brown white can
all thrive right
um and so talking about systemic racism
um
i'd like to just kind of quickly give
like a definition so systemic racism is
grounded in history
our laws institutions and it combines
you know it's a combination basically of
these systems and factors
in the united states that gives
advantages to white people
and has disadvantaged in access and
opportunity for people of color
so when we're talking about sexism it's
going to advantage
it's giving an advantage to men for
example um that
that woman and non-binary peoples don't
have access and opportunity as well
so um talking about systemic racism and
sexism we're talking about things like
the fact in new hampshire
woman makes 74 cents to every dollar a
man makes
and it's even worse if you're a woman of
color in new hampshire the rates is
uh for we basically rank 45th in the
nation
for gender pay equality and that's a
shame right
in higher education it's even worse that
gap
um when we talk about systemic racism
we're also talking about the fact that
in 2018
the poverty rate for whites in new
hampshire was one in 14
for blacks it's one and five
for the latinx community it's one and
six again compare that to one and four
poverty rate for white granite staters
so um also looking about looking at the
criminal justice system in new hampshire
if the black community is 1.7 percent of
the new hampshire population
we must ask why do they make up 7 of the
prison
and jail population so that's what we
mean by systemic racism
so uh he talks about um uh
being objective and subjective uh and so
this bill is is wildly dangerous because
when we're saying that
oh you can teach about all these things
but you must be
you know objective about it one like has
to ask
like who gets to decide what's objective
and subjective
right who gets to decide if a student
was failed
because of this reason or not right um
especially in the context that i shared
about why the bill was even introduced
right which is to curb this this this
energy or this movement around
addressing systemic racism so many
people um
stated including the president of the
new hampshire business and industry
association
that they are really worried about this
bill
because businesses who get funding from
the state
contracts with um trainers basically
they contract with trainers and they
found
that the conversations are necessary to
ensure they aren't engaging in racism
and sexism
and that these trainings will help them
ensure they aren't
you know vulnerable to race and gender
discrimination
so we have teachers doctors businesses
all these people who've come out
against this bill saying this is really
really bad
for our state so i know he says it only
affects state contractors let's talk
about that
it's important to understand that all
all public schools are partially funded
by the state so it's going to affect
all our public schools right um and then
let's talk about hospitals
all our hospitals are going to be
affected by this bill including
dartmouth
because we get uh the hospitals get
medicaid
through state you know through state
funds so it's going to affect all
hospitals
and it's going to affect businesses who
contract with this uh with
with people giving these trainings who
get state funds
and then it's also going to affect
organizations and advocacy groups
who contract um uh with with you know
with trainers
that get funding from the state so
literally this is going to affect
many many people in in our state and so
um yeah i just want to maybe stop there
and then
open it up for questions
thank you so much yeah absolutely
questions on the table
if not um i have one to begin with but
feel free to
raise your hands if you have any um
oh yeah read go ahead is this bill
being i this is kind of to anyone is
this bill being brought up in any other
state
at the moment and if so what's that
looking like
um if it's already been approved or
what they've done with it yes
actually it has been introduced in other
states in one
form or another and i believe there was
one state who fully passed it
like the governor signed it and
everything if i'm not mistaken it's
iowa or idaho i can look that and get
you that answer
i believe yeah sorry to interrupt i
believe it i believe it was iowa just
because i have some legislators that are
friends over there
i believe it was that thank you
are there any other questions
um can i add like the interesting thing
is um
one of the things that that i do want to
mention like i really feel like this is
going to create
a nanny state you know like in our
schools and businesses the schools
basically are going to say it's not
worth having our funding threatened
in a situation when some parents might
find something objectionable right so
this is really even if like our states
or our local
governments want to have these
conversations they're going to steer
away with a bill like this because
they're afraid you know they'll get sued
or whatever it's now a state law so
just want to kind of kind of share that
i know that um oh wait i will pass it to
ryan and then drew
um i just wanted to say thank you for
really saying that all like
succinctly and really highlighting
important uh aspects of it because it is
important to address the systemic racism
racism in not only the united states but
our state and i was wondering
when we go to say like testify for the
bill or talk with other people about it
do you have any like tips for us of like
important
um aspects of the build a highlight or
anything that could like convey the same
message that you did
yeah um i could definitely send you some
research because i know the legislature
loves research
so when we say when we're talking about
systemic racism this is what we're
talking about and i think it's really
helpful to say
um particularly as white people and as
men so
men should come to should actually say
hey we want to hear how
how sexism is you know um manifesting
in our state and so i think that'll be a
good thing and i think if you're white
to say hey we want to hear how racism
is manifesting in our state because we
can't address these issues if we can't
have conversations about them
thank you so much jude did you have a
question
yeah i had a question for everyone i
think i personally have
never had an agenda of having to
say america is racist on a test or
anything remotely resembling that
um i think if anything the agenda that
has affected
me or maybe not the agenda but is the
omission of certain events
in american history that could be
construed as racist or sexist
or maybe the complete omission of things
like the gay rights movement
in schools that is more what i've been
affected by
but i wanted to just ask everyone has
anyone ever had a personal experience
with anything
um resembling what representative animan
was talking about
i'm i'm so i'm just gonna um is are
there any other final questions um for
asthma before we
um go into discussion and i i don't want
to disrupt the conversation but at least
um and the questioning i have one if no
one else does
um can i just piggyback off of that
wonderful question because
i also haven't seen any any proof
of teachers ever telling any students
that they're
born racist never so when these
allegations are made
i'm sorry to say i just don't believe
any teacher has ever said yes
i believe white people are born racist
and these are you know some examples
like i've never heard that so if people
are out alleging that that has happened
they have to come forth with some real
proof
that this is what teachers are actually
saying because what teachers are doing
is saying because of systemic racism
whether through you know the way we're
portrayed in the media or movies
um we develop biases and we need to be
aware of them to dismantle them right
so that's just another point that i just
want to say because i've never there was
never real proof of any teacher saying
people are born racist
yeah and that's okay that's what my
question hinges around so
i'll be very quick um i i know that
rights and democracy does a lot of work
centered around human rights and
um diversity equity inclusion um so at
the bottom of this bill it says
and i quote that nothing shall prevent
agencies or contractors from promoting
racial cultural or ethnic diversity or
inclusiveness
as long as they comply with this bill um
but i wanted to hear your thoughts on
that because
and this is my own understanding but if
you
prohibit the discussion of the reasons
for which there may be a lack of
diversity
and inclusivity to begin with wouldn't
it be rather ineffective to
promote diversity and inclusion
especially through you know
education and foster that kind of
inclusive workspace if we aren't able to
address the root causes and um i wanted
to hear your thoughts on that especially
as someone who works for diversity and
equity and inclusion
yeah so um i guess i want to make sure i
got the question right are you saying
that if we aren't having these
conversations
then um there's no way to actually be
able to address
the issues of racism and sexism yes
exactly so
um you know encourage agency employees
not to judge each other by their color
racism
ethnicity sex or any other
characteristic but
is there any how can we do that if um we
are not discussing the underlying causes
for any discrimination
that's precisely it you literally
answered your own question and you're
brilliant
so you just say that we're we'll be
wonderful
and good in the legislature
thank you so much all right i want to
thank i want to thank both of our guest
speakers we're just going to kind of
transition over to a quick conversation
i'm trying to have a kind of a deadline
four o'clock 4 15.
um i stepped away from work so um do our
best to get that but
um let's just kick it off lincoln just
passed back to you
yeah wonderful um well thank you both so
much for joining us
it was very helpful to hear these
perspectives um and i think this is now
our time as a council to bring forth any
sort of questions you might have for
each other
um and also just any thoughts we have
and our goal is to be able to vote on
this legislation so i think
perhaps the first thing to think about
is do you feel prepared to vote on it
and is there anything you'd like to
discuss and hash out before we do so
does anyone have any sort of points they
want to bring up oh representative ammon
yeah i just want to say uh i'll leave
you guys to your deliberation
um going first was a little bit of a
disadvantage
and i'm happy to talk about any
rebuttals
later uh in you know the opposition we
live in a society where
we get to have two we get to hear both
sides of an argument and that's how we
get to the truth so
i appreciate you letting me uh talk to
you and i'm gonna
disappear and let you guys deliberate
okay thank you thank you so much for
coming
all right i'll open it up to anyone who
might have any thoughts maybe we can
start with your question jude um for
everyone which is really centered around
have
you experienced any situations
um that propagate these divisive
concepts
in the way that is outlined in this bill
um
what do you all think feel free to just
unmute yourselves this is really our
time and i think
we can use it however you all feel best
i would say i definitely have not where
a teacher is prompted that
exact discussion saying that america
is like racist where it absolutely is i
think
based on the very foundation and the way
african americans people of color women
were treated
during its creation and today but i
think that
because people feel uncomfortable when
we do bring up these topics like the
civil rights movement slavery in school
i think that like some people might feel
targeted and that brings them to think
oh like they're saying that white people
are racist or america is racist
whereas really they're just being
presented the facts of what happened
and it's like well yes it did and
that is what happened so i don't know i
don't think people are directly being
told
they're racist
yeah and if i may uh to just back off
that i think that
uh the idea that
any discussion around systemic racism
will you know will equal
uh guilt i think that's
misguided i think that you know
in my school we've been able to have
some very nuanced mature conversations
about
systemic racism and how real it is and
so i just think that that's something
um somewhat building off what sam just
said
when when i discuss like white privilege
for example
within school i've never heard someone
say
like you have white privilege you should
feel really guilty it's more of an
acknowledgement
you know it's more like i understand
that this is something that
is unfair and that might happen to me
because of my race and it's something we
need a change
but not something you need to feel
guilty about because
you can't really do anything about it as
an individual
obviously i can't change my race so i
think
this bill might prevent some discussions
such as that happening
within schools and
other parts of our society
i think going upon that and um one of my
main things with the bill and i think
brian touched on
is like who gets to decide whether or
not something is difficult concept so as
representative and was talking about
it's like um the onus is on the parent
or the child to like bring it up to the
school board
and then from the school board right
then we go further and i think the thing
is that we
all kind of when making these decisions
right we probably already have
preconceived notions
as we were talking about like someone
probably already knows where they fall
on whether or not they think america is
like a racist country for example and so
i think then at the end they just come
back to politics and i think
at the end of the day it's kind of
deciding right and having like this
objective
standard is kind of missing from the
spill saying okay
um this is where we draw the line and
for me that's kind of one of my main
issues with
this film
back breaking up with carson i think i
think that's a very good point because
we can talk about things as far as like
oh what's right or wrong but i think the
most important thing when we're thinking
about our students and educators is
what's going to make people the most
comfortable
and in my mind the people that are going
to be the most
uncomfortable are going to be those
groups that are marginalized that might
be
getting that might be experiencing these
in like inequalities but we can't talk
about it
i feel like the people that the people
that are
i don't want to say privilege because
that's the whole com another
conversation that
um we can get into but like who is who
is truly being
made uncomfortable and will this bill
make them more comfortable or less
comfortable like
how is this actually going to affect the
students mentally
yeah for sure and then there's also the
whole freedom of speech angle like
it might create this culture where you
know as as carson pointed out
this bill is rather vague and kind of
saying what what is divisive i mean
there are a few definitions but like
something could you know make me angry
just because i haven't reckoned with my
own privilege
you know that again as lisa that's
getting into like a whole other
conversation but
you know do i get to decide what is and
isn't divisive
do the three sponsors of this bill who i
might add
are white and male get to decide um
like who who has that chance and then it
might create this culture within schools
and within the government
of people trying to you know scope out
and twist words and report each other
and i'm not sure whether that's like in
the interest of freedom of speech and
also just creating that inclusive
community like i'm
i would be worried about the
consequences
um just you know of this whole reporting
mechanism which isn't very clear
in the bill itself as well as as carson
said when it comes to putting that
owners on the parents
and on the students and on the employees
how will that be reported how will
what kind of repercussions will there be
if the teacher
within a school promotes or like talks
about systemic racism
would that mean that eventually the
state's contract with the entire school
would be terminated cutting the funding
and the education for an entire
district's
students like i'm not entirely sure but
that's
that's something that i think is worth
thinking about
yeah i agree i think overall this bill
would like
almost scare like teachers or
administrations from
from and steer them away from talking
about like important issues
or important like historical events and
stuff because they wouldn't want to get
penalized for this and hurt their school
funding or get in trouble with their
school and stuff like that i think it
would just
it would do more harm
does anyone have any other thoughts um
how do we feel about voting on this do
we feel like we have enough
information um
um i just i just kind of want a little
bit of feedback has this been helpful to
do a kind of a panel of style i think on
yeah i'm seeing nods so i'm think on
like positions of contentious bills
maybe next year
um i was talking to a link a little bit
about it but uh
you know kind of give me a heads up of
what we wanted to talk about and then
invite
um a pro and against for the bills that
we can kind of hear from people and then
uh respond that way so i think this
conversation has been great
uh regardless of where i personally
stand on the position and representative
ammon
i just want to thank the council for
where they
you know their vote and their opinion so
thank you
thank you and i i think you know as
exemplified by the nods it's been super
helpful because
sometimes just breaking down a nebulous
bill into
you know something that makes sense and
we can vote on knowing
different sides can be really tough and
this was really helpful
um how does everyone feel can we vote
wait a roll call but okay i think
molly you're taking minutes are you good
for a roll call vote
so there should be a motion there should
be a motion from somebody
to support or oppose and then the
vote would be whether whatever the
motion is do you support
like yes to the motion or no emotion
okay i'm motioned to oppose
all right um going down the list
alphabetically
carson uh i will support the motion to
oppose
awesome um harrison
i'm going to abstain
isabelle i support the motion to
oppose i also support the motion to
oppose
jude i support the motion
casey i support the motion
let's see um lily i support the motion
matti i support the motion
meg i support the motion too
reed i support the motion
ryan i support the motion sam
i support the motion to oppose
all right good work everybody and it's
exactly four
that was a lot accomplished in an hour
so good job everyone
um rob alexander what do you think are
the next steps for this bill since it's
um in the budget as well and
yeah in terms of us making our opinion
heard
so the 544 i looked on the docket that's
been tabled
um um in the basically the
the bill is is um in in the budget that
was passed by the house so the house
position
um so i guess i would
say to draft up a statement and send it
out saying you oppose the content
of what's in um 544
and most legislators will understand
that and send it to the house as well as
the senate
all right right now right now the
budget's in the senate's hands so
um it will come back to the house but
the house is already voted on 544
basically in the in the button sounds
good
all right um in that case we will write
up an email with
all the information on this and don't
forget to check out the google drive and
all the spreadsheets there just so that
we can keep working
um keep testifying and we'll also send
out a document so we can all collaborate
on a statement on this given that this
is something that we've all
sort of been discussing together and
it's overarching
um for the council um and i know that we
probably have to adjourn
soon so before that do you have any
questions or thoughts um
for us
so next meeting we just talked um a link
and i talked
can you just address that first and kind
of what we're going to talk about and
then
you can adjourn absolutely so our next
meeting we're considering
june 13th so if as soon as we get that
scheduled we'll let you know
um and the goal for next meeting is to
have sort of an open discussion
on how the council went this year what
progress we've made
ways we can be more effective next year
and also talking about how we can
continue taking action over the summer
even when we might not be meeting
especially since some of the bills that
we've voted on
are probably going to be worked on over
the summer by different committees and
will want to be involved in some
capacity so
next meeting's kind of going to be an
open discussion type
meeting so we can recap brainstorm for
ways to just make the council
run more smoothly and also plan for next
year and
it looks like we'll be able to have a
summit at the state house hopefully
in august so that's the goal we're
working towards that
um and rep alexander is also working on
organizing a
possible meeting in august as well with
the clark which will be
really informative and a great
opportunity so there's a lot of exciting
stuff to come
but please let us know soon if you
cannot make it to the upcoming meeting
and please keep checking the google
drive and the emails that we send
and come prepared next time just to kind
of recap
all right thanks everyone have a great
evening thank you love everyone
see you all soon